[Music]
it's great to see so many people here
interested in testing my name is
jonathan garish and together with my
colleague Yuki Hamada we're going to be
presenting a session on testing api's
today so just to get started just hands
up anyone who's written unit tests it's
not a trick question
good and what about integration tests
you can be honest awesome
ok let's get started so on Android
there's two kinds of tests you might be
familiar with there's local unit tests
and then there's instrumentation tests
so let's start by looking at local unit
tests so these are ones that these are
tests that are executed on your local
developers workstation on the local VM
running there and because they you don't
need to run the entire Android build
chain your void external and installing
on a device these tests are actually
really really fast
on these kind of tests you can use a
tool like robolectric which comes with
its own set of testing api's for setting
up the state of your android environment
or you can use a tool like Marketo and
you can stub out the interactions with
the android framework and either way
they allow you to write tests setting up
the state of the environment that
satisfy the preconditions that you might
want in your test case the second kind
of tests are instrumentation tests now
these are the tests that will run on a
virtual or a real device a real device
could just be a phone connected to your
workstation or it could be a farm of
devices somewhere in the cloud these
kind of tests run slower because you
have to execute the whole build chain
and install an application onto the
device but they have the advantage of
being a lot more accurate because the
real or virtual device is a very similar
some cases identical to devices that
your users will be using out in the
field and this brings you the confidence
that your app is going to behave as you
expect one criticism we have heard is
that these kind of tests there's
actually a lack of testing API is
available which makes it difficult for
you to set up the state of your
environment in a way that satisfies
certain preconditions or edge cases that
you might want to be testing and so
we've heard you loud and clear and this
is something we're actively working on
it's a bit of a little history lesson on
2017 at Google i/o we presented what we
call the Android testing story say based
loosely around like the software
development pyramid and in this model we
encourage you to write lots and lots of
fast scalable unit tests that test all
your exhaustive conditions we encourage
you to write a smaller number of
instrumentation tests that will actually
prove that all these units assemble
together behave as you would expect on a
real device and in some ways this was
kind of a compromise it was a compromise
between the advantages of one set of one
kind of test and the trade-offs of
another so it brings you a like a
holistic way of testing your app and we
showed how this kind of approach can
lead to test rim development on Android
first of all you would start with a
failing UI test this would be an
instrumentation task probably written
with espresso and it would test the UI
of your of your component your feature
and then you would satisfy that feature
by a series of units classes coming
together their interactions and you
could test drive these as well using a
tool like robolectric or mojito running
on as a local test and this gives you
very fast development cycles finally
when you bring them all together you're
able to run
slower running but more faithful
instrumentation test and hopefully it
goes green and you're done well we enter
a refactoring cycle because maybe you
your code leaves a little to be desired
and you want to do some cleanup and so
you can spend some refactoring cycles
there before coming around to the
beginning of the cycle where if you have
any more work on the feature you might
add another test
test another aspect to that feature and
you'll keep iterating until you complete
at which time you're good to submit your
code and move on to the next task so at
Google i/o this year we realized there
was a somewhat of a test writing crisis
and because there's so many tools
available it's not always clear which
one to use and each of these tools all
have their own different styles and
api's and paradigms for these same
concepts that exist on Android and the
problem with this is that tests written
in different levels are not portable
across levels your test is kind of stuck
it's coupled to the testing tool and
environment that you've written it on so
this year at Google i/o we announced
beta of Android X tests it brings
testing as a first-class citizen as part
of the tool chain as part of jetpack did
we include some of the existing
libraries you've used before some new
API is full Kotlin support which allows
you to write really beautiful and
concise tests and it's available on and
off device well last week Android X
tests moved out of beta and tour the
first full and final release 1.0 it's
also as of last week fully open sourced
and so we look forward to welcoming your
contributions and all of the
documentation on developer.android.com
slash training slash testing there's all
been revamped to show you the new styles
of api's so please don't check that out
so let's take a look inside
the first module that we pulled across
was the existing je unit for support and
the runner and the roles that you may
have used before we've also added a new
module which we call core and this
includes some new api's application
provider as its name suggests it's a
quick and easy way to get a hold of the
application context activity scenario
which is a brand new API that provides
coarse and fine grained
api's for which you can test your
activities and fragment scenario which
was released actually just this week
providing this very similar set of
testing features for fragments we've
also brought espresso into the jetpack
Android X family espresso if you're not
aware is a set of view matching library
filled with a set of view matching api's
and a set of view actions it's allow you
to match and then in interact with those
UI elements it also includes some other
things like ability to capture and stub
intense for the system and finally we've
also released some truth Android
extensions and truth is Google's open
source fluent testing assertions library
and we brought in a bunch of components
for Android subjects which allow you to
test your Android objects in a way that
reads beautifully and concisely and
those have you been using robolectric
we'll know that we've had a version 4.0
and beta for a while and as of last week
we did a simultaneous release that's now
gone into final robolectric 4 fully
supports all of the unified API is that
are in Android X test as well as a
number of its
new features and improvements okay and
so I'd like to welcome you key onstage
who's gonna give you a deeper dive into
some of the api's available yuki $6
sound hi everyone so let me introduce
our new api's let's start with
application provider which is a new way
of accessing context from your test
board so when you work on Android
testing you need to handle two different
contexts object
the first one is come from come from
application sorry the first one is come
from application under your test and the
second one is come from the
instrumentation apk where your test code
is stored so with today's a today's
library we have two different methods to
access this context object and this
makes your test code harder to
understand because the library uses
library specific terminology target
context means context from your
instrumentation apk while sorry the
target context means the context from
your application while get get context
means the context from your
instrumentation apk also it is it is not
obviously which one to use for your test
so in our new API we hide the
instrumentation content from public API
and we only and only application
provider only provides application
context in the form over your
application graph
let's take a look at the example code so
here let's say we have a test for the
location tracker activity and in the
setup method we get that we get the
target context in the old-fashioned way
and we type just it to a location
tracker application so that we can
register a mock mock object for testing
and second line set the mock object for
that and this code is pretty simple and
it actually works but you could have
used our own context and face-to-face
terrain time at runtime error and ended
up with wasting your time for debugging
now with the new way a previous
application context provider provides
your context in a in your application
class so you can do the exactly the same
thing but there is much less chance for
our confusion or baggage okay listen let
me move on to the more complicated stuff
activity scenario actually before I we
dive into details I have a question for
you how many of you have written your
own activity and and handle the
lifecycle transitions by you up by
yourself please raise your hand if you
are cool and how many of you have
shipped to your activity with with the
bodies related to life cycles Oh
many of you and who didn't like a taste
for that as we did not write a test cool
well yeah I I see some 100 keeping up
and to be honest I do too and I agree
the writing test for the activity
activity lifecycle transition is pretty
hard and there is no such a good API in
testing library as now so that's why me
and the Jonathan and our team have
sought for a solution
and we develop the activity scenario
which you can use it for driving your
activity stay tuned arbitrary state for
testing so let's revisit the activities
activity state first so the creative
state is where an activity is created
I mean instantiated but it is but it is
not visible to users yet or activity
opportunity so it can be creative state
while it is running in background as
well and the study state is we are
activity is created in study it's
partially visible to users but not the
Frog on foreground activity activities
running in picture-in-picture mode is
also in this state and a reasonable
state if we are your activity is fully
visible to users and running in
foreground and in and under the
framework can change the lifecycle state
by anytime by the user user interactions
so your activity has to handle those
state transition property for a good
user experience otherwise you see some
bugs and activity scenario provides a
method movie to state which you can
drive your activities like circus like
cycle stay tuned arbitrary state for
testing let's take a look at an example
called here we have a test for a
location tracker activity and here we
want to verify that location listener is
properly unregistered from the system
when the activity becomes creative state
so at first we have to start activity
launch activity takes your activity your
activity class and start activity and
wait wait for it until it becomes
resuming the state and move it to state
initiated lifecycle transition and movie
star lifecycle state to the creative
state also the older method all the
activities module method works as a
blocking call so
after this after this methodical it is
guaranteed that the activities lifecycle
state to be created and then you can
inspect your activities internal state
by calling own activity method yes
that's easy now we have a API and also
you can use activity scenario for
testing the creation of your activity so
activity recreation happens when you are
your activity is running in background
for a long time and when you come back
it later and your activity has to save
its its internal state to establish
saved internal save this stable instance
a bundle before it is destroyed
otherwise you will lose the state and
activity study has a method recreate we
are you can use it for testing such a
scenario this see our example code so
here in this test we want to make sure
that input text is restore the property
after the activity is recreated after
destruction so first we have a some test
data like test user as an input and
again we start activity and then we
input we fill the text box by using the
espresso library as you can see the
activity scenario works pretty nicely
with espresso and then we call recreate
which actually leak with which actually
destroyed live activity and recreate the
new instance and waits waits for the
activity to be resumed in state and then
again using the espresso again and we
can make sure that the text is there
I'll be expected yes it's also simple ok
finally I'd like to show you one more
example from the truth tooth extension
in 10 subjects by use of intense subject
you can verify your you can verify your
intent values and
and it produces really good
human-friendly error messages if the
error happens let's see an example
called
in this time we want to again make sure
that intent we want to make sure our
data intent has a expected contact name
in it extras so first we create a bundle
of the data intent and then we assert by
three lines one is checking if that
intent has expected action and the
second one is type and the third one is
the extra bundles and if the value
doesn't match your expectation you see
this error as you can see like you can
immediately know the in this example the
intent action is not is not what you
expected and yellow lots of a component
come with under the x1 under the XS 1.0
and I can't show you everything today
well for example like we have more
assertions and we also have under the
builders we are you can create your
testing data easily and also scenarios
for activity and fragments and you can
take a look at this link or
documentation to see more I hope you to
try it out after the talk ok so this is
the our solution for the test writing
crisis so with unified API you no longer
need to you no longer consider video to
write instrumentation test or the
robolectric test because you can now
just write a under your test and that
test runs on both both grunt both
runtime environments nicely so with the
unified API you can focus on what to
test and you can forget about where and
how and to ensure the consistency of the
behavior of our API we have a
verification test and we run the same
test against
sorry we run the same test on locally
with robolectric and also we run our
tests on virtual devices from the AP
from the API level 15 to the latest
version and and this bug go back to the
workflow we showed you earlier in this
talk so we can execute the test
test-driven development much more
efficiently using the device agnostic
test with the Dostal test writing in a
unified API as our recommendation we
recommend that you run the you write the
test and a Rando test with the lab
electric and then until your code is
ready to submit and and then run doubt
run the same test but on the virtual
devices before actually you submit a
test to maximise your confidence also
you can run the same test as a
continuous integration test against the
nightly built binary with the upcoming
nitrogen to change you can set up such a
configuration easily if you if you want
to know more about the project nitrogen
we have a session tomorrow so and we
highly recommend attending it Kurt I
thank you very much for listening and
have a havi testing
[Applause]
[Music]